If you have ever looked
for your car keys,
or been lost in an
unfamiliar place,
you know how
incredibly useful it
is to understand and
remember your surroundings.
Project Tango is adding this
capability to mobile devices,
so they can track their motion,
recognize faces, and scan
the surroundings in 3D.
Its ability to
recognize spaces means
it can determine its exact
position, find your car keys,
and remember where you put
your virtual pet monster.
In this episode, we will talk
about area learning concepts
and how to get started with
Project Tango Explorer.
Project Tango combines
visual and inertial data
to give mobile devices
an understanding
of position and orientation.
It gets the visual
data from its cameras,
and the inertial data from
its built-in acceleration
and rotation sensors.
This is combined into motion
tracking data, which provides
the device relative motion.
Area Learning extends this
data to remember areas
and to estimate the device
position within them.
You can use this for
multiple purposes,
such as precise
indoor navigation,
placing virtual objects
in the physical world,
or to share a virtual
world with other users.
To use area learning,
you must first
learn an area so the system
will be able to recognize
the area later.
The combination of
learning and localization
is similar to what humans do.
When you enter a new
building, you quickly
get a picture of
its layout, and you
can use this memory to find
your way around at a later time.
Project Tango saves
the learned memories
into an area description
file, or ADF.
This file contains descriptions
of visual landmarks
that the system uses when
looking for known places.
An ADF enables the device
to estimate its position
through a process we
call localization.
Another important
aspect of area learning
is that the device can
refine its position estimate
relative to the area it is in.
This is great if you want
to fixate a virtual world
in the physical world.
For example, if you want to put
an elephant in the living room
and have it stay there,
without area learning
the system can only
estimate its position
based on small increments
in the motion of the device.
This method introduces
inaccuracies,
as it requires incredibly
precise sensors
to be able to track
motion like this.
Just imagine you had
to count your steps
and turns to be able
to know where you are.
It's error prone.
Area learning sidesteps
this whole issue
by storing visual
references that it can
use to calculate its position.
In other words, the
ADF is the frame
of reference in area learning.
To make area
description files, you
can either implement area
learning in your own app,
or use a developer tool
like Project Tango Explorer
to learn an area.
But first you need to know
that area descriptions are not
created equal.
It's possible to learn an
area with different levels
of quality depending on how much
of the area you have learned.
For instance, it's going to make
a big difference if you only
take a picture from one
perspective versus taking
pictures of all the
perspectives of a room.
The more coverage
you have, the easier
it will be for the device to
recall it has been in the area
before.
It is important to note that the
success of area learning also
depends on visual
characteristics
of the environment.
An ideal environment has
distinguishing visual features,
mostly stationary objects, and
does not change much over time.
Environments that
are visually bland,
such as long,
undecorated hallways,
or places with a
lot of moving people
can be harder for the
system to remember.
Light also changes
the way things look.
So if the lighting conditions
vary a lot in the area,
you may need to have
a couple of ADFs
for the brightest and
darkest time of day.
Project Tango allows you
to learn and load an ADF.
The ADF will be stored
in the flash memory,
and can be used in other
apps to find the position
and orientation.
You can download Explorer
from the Play Store,
but let's go through how
it works in practice.
In the default mode,
click the learn button
to create a new
ADF, and walk around
in the area in one direction.
Remember, the system
benefits from having
seen more of the space, so
once done walking around,
walk back in the
opposite direction.
This increases the coverage
and makes it easier
to use the ADF later.
In the end, we save
the ADF to a file.
It then takes three steps
to localize in the area.
First, be in an area
that has been learned
and for which there is an ADF.
Second, load the
ADF for the area.
And third, move the device to
compare the ADF to the area.
Once the system has
recognized the area,
you will be receiving real-time
updates on the position
and orientation of the device.
You will only see a blue
trace in the beginning,
and until the system
figures out where it is.
This is the relative
motion tracking trace,
which you can learn more
about in the Introduction
to Motion Tracking video.
As soon as the system recognizes
the area using the ADF,
a green trace will appear.
This is the position
of the device
in the area you have learned.
The system now uses the learned
data to correct the device
position within this area.
Area learning adds the
ability to visually recognize
known areas, and locate
the device within them.
Whether you want to have
a monster under your bed,
or have an elephant
in your living room,
area learning will
allow you to do that.
Visit our Google+ community,
and join us on our journey.
We're excited to see what you
will build with Project Tango.
[MUSIC PLAYING]